The Joe Rogan experience. So how did you learn how to do all this stuff?
Was it trial by fire when you're learning how to use all this? I mean,
I don't want to call it ancient equipment,
but mechanical equipment to figure out how to yeah.
Yeah. Secret is to begin. Just start. Yeah. I mean, so.
[Inaudible] where the does one learn how to operate a sextant and
then navigate in the ocean?
Uh, yeah, just, I would, you know, I started, uh, you know,
me and some friends got a boat and, um,
we started fixing it up and making a lot of mistakes. And then, you know,
I started taking some trips and then lost. Yeah, I got lost a bunch.
I took a solo trip from San Francisco to Mexico and back, uh,
on a little 27 foot boat with no engine. And.
So when did that take a few months? Yeah.
And the way you did it, did you stay close so I can see the there's the shore.
So if everything up, I can kind of swim.
Yeah, well, no, you can answer them. Uh, I learned that lesson to know why it's,
um, I mean the closest I ever came to death in my life,
uh, was just in the Bay, in the San Francisco Bay.
I was on a boat that capsized and, um,
I was probably 2000 yards away from shore and, uh,
I almost drowned and I, I mean, I didn't make it. Sure. And, um, yeah,
it's just the motor so cold, you know, didn't make it to shore. No, yeah.
It's a long story. I was like, um, I,
a friend of mine was living in San Francisco and he wanted to learn how to sail.
And I was like, you know,
what you should do is you should get like a little boat,
like a little sailing di you know, and then you can just anchor it,
like off the shore in this area that no one cares about. And, you know,
you can just sort of experiment with this little boat.
And so he started looking on Craigslist and he found this boat it's for sale for
500 bucks up in, uh, up in the North Bay. And, uh,
every time we called the phone number, we got done an answering machine.
It was like, hello, you've reached Dr. Ken Thompson honorary.
I'm unable to take your call, you know? And we were like,
what is that like honorary fake doctor? Is he like a judge? You know,
like, what is it? Yeah. And so finally we got in touch with this guy.
We go out there and it's this, this is the kind of situation where like,
we pull up and there's like the trailer that the boat's supposed to go on.
And it just full of scrap metal. And, you know, and you know, this guy comes in,
he's like, Oh yeah, this is the trailer. Um, we were going to do a metal run,
but if you want the boat, you know, we'll take the metal off, you know?
And we're like, okay, you know, and he's like taking us around he's he's like,
okay, the masters over here. And it's like, under symbol leaves, you know,
it was like, and then, you know, that the hole is in the water here and it's,
he has like a dock behind his house. And the tide is all the way out the books,
just sitting in the mud, you know? And I'm like, well,
how would we get this out of here? He's like, Oh,
you'd have to come back at a different time. Uh, you know,
and then you take it over there and we're like, you told us to come now,
like at this time, you know, anyway. So we go through all of the thing,
you know, and, and you know, my friend who knows nothing about boats, it's like,
all right, Moxie, like, what do you think? You know, should I get this?
And I was like, okay. Oh. And we were like, so what's it you doctor of what?
He's like, Oh, self-declared, you know, we're like, Oh.
He's a self-declared doctor, honorary, honorary. Self-declared doctor.
You can do that.
I guess. Why not? It's just an answer, Jamie.
Yes. Yes. I think we should become doctors. Right.
It just became one. I tried that for a while,
actually. Yeah. Did you really, I don't know. I mean,
I never went to college though.
Does Thompson ever get an honorary degree or did he just call himself Dr.
Hunter S Thompson, because he was calling himself Dr. Hunter S Thompson.
Oh, bill Cosby became a doctor for a little bit. They took it back though.
How'd she know he up. Yeah. Yeah. He'd take back your fake doctor degree. Yeah.
So this guy was like, you know, my friends, like, what do you think Mexican?
I'm like, all right, Dr. Ken, I would have to consider it.
I'm not sure that I would do it, but I would consider taking this boat for free.
I'd have to think about it, but I would consider that, you know, and he's like,
I might be a minimal to that, you know? So we've gone from like, you know,
$500 to free. Uh, and so we got this boat, you know,
and it was something we had to deal with the metal and all the stuff we got the
boat. And, um, we were just trying to do like a little, um,
we're just trying to anchor it all. Did you bring life vests? Yeah,
I was wearing a, uh, a PFD, uh, type type two PFD.
And, um, uh, we took it,
we took it to this boat ramp and it was the end of the day.
And the wind was blowing kind of hard and the conditions weren't that good,
but I was like, Oh, we're just doing this little thing, this little maneuver.
And we were in two boats, I built this little wooden, uh, rowing boat. Uh,
and my friend was going to go out in that with one anchor and I was going to
sail out this whole tip yeah. Of, uh, plywood, a stitching glue. Uh, but yeah.
Uh, and, but it, you know, not the sturdiest vessel. So,
uh, and so, you know,
he's going to go out in this little rowboat and I was going to sail out this,
uh, this little catamaran and we had two anchors and we're gonna anchor and they
were going to get in the rowboat and row back. And, um,
it seemed a little windy. And, you know,
I got in the boat first and I got out around this pier and was hit by the full
force of the wind and realized that it was blowing like 20 knots is way,
way too much for what we were trying to do,
but I had missed rigged part of the boat.
So it took me a while to get it turned around. Um,
and by the time I got it turned around, my friend had wrote out, um,
around the pier and he got hit by the force of the wind and just got blown out
into the Bay.
So he's rowing directly into the wind and moving backwards out of the Bay.
And I was like. And I'm on this little Hoby cat. And it was moving so fast.
It was way too windy to be sailing this thing. I've got just my clothes on.
I don't have a wetsuit on or anything like that.
I have a life jacket and just my clothes and we don't have a radio. We don't,
you know, we're unprepared, it's starting to get dark. We don't have a light.
Um, and I'm sailing back and forth trying to like help my friend. Uh,
and it got to the point where I was like, all right,
I'm just going to tack over. I'm going to sail up, uh,
to this boat that was called the sea Laos, sail up to the sea.
I'm going to get my friend off of it. We're just going to abandon it.
And then we're going to sail this Hoby cat back if we can.
And so I go to turn around and right, as I'm turning around a gust of wind,
hit the boat and capsized it before I could even know that it was, you know,
just, it's just like you just, it's one moment. You're on the button.
The next moment you're in the water, you know?
And the water was like 50 degrees, um, like super, uh, it, like,
it was a shock, you know,
it hits you and the boat was a little messed up in a way where
it, I couldn't write it. Uh, it, it, it capsized. And then the whole, it,
it capsized all the way and then sink. And so it was floating like, like,
you know, three feet underwater basically. Um, and so I'm in the water,
but I'm like still, I'm like a little bit out of the water,
but like in the water. And, you know,
I had a cell phone that just immediately was busted. Um,
and I look at my friend and he's always away now and he didn't see me.
And I was, you know, yelling as loud as I could,
but the wind is blowing 20 knots. And it just, you know,
you can't hear each other, you know, just takes your, takes her voice away.
And, um, he just, I mean, I was screaming, I was waving,
he wasn't wearing his glasses and he just very slowly wrote away.
Oh my God.
And so then I was just like floating there. I was starting to get dark. Um,
you know, I wrote.
Away, did he notice that your boated capsize?
No. He didn't even see me. He, he thought that I had just sailed somewhere else,
you know? Cause in his mind he was, I was the person with the experience.
You still talk to this dude? Yeah. All the time. Yeah. I feel.
Like you. I don't blame.
Him in his mind. He was the person that was in trouble. Right. You know, and,
and he thought I just sailed somewhere else.
That's crazy. Yeah. Sierra a of vision.
Yeah. And then, you know, it, it basically, it got dark. I could see the shore.
It wasn't far away. There was nobody on shore. There's nobody around. And, um,
the wind was blowing directly off shore. So you have to swim, you know,
swim into the wind, uh, in, into the wind wave and all that stuff. And um,
eventually I tried swimming and I swam, you know, directly upwind. And I was,
cause I was, I was like, okay,
like if I get separated from this boat and I don't make it to shore,
then I'm definitely dead. You know? Like there's just no saving me. Uh,
so I was trying to go directly up when,
so that if I felt like I couldn't make it,
I would float back down when it hit the boat again. And so I tried, you know,
I swam for probably like 20 minutes up point and made no progress.
It didn't feel like any progress. You know, my, you know,
in 50 degrees you have 30 to 60 minutes before you black out. My arms were just,
you know, it's like, I consider myself a strong swimmer. Like I free dive,
you know, all this stuff. And I just, you know,
it's like you read these stories about, uh, how people die, you know,
of just like they succumb to hypothermia on a local hike or they drown in the
Bay, you know? And the story is always like, well, Timmy was a strong swimmer,
but he drove in and you're like really was Timmy really a strong swimmer because
he'd drown in the bed, you know? And like floating there, you know,
it just all came to me. I'm like, wow, this is how this happens. You know,
you just make a series of pretty dumb,
small decisions until you find yourself like floating in the dark in the Bay.
There's no one around and it's a really slow process too. You know? It's like.
It's not like, you know, you.
Just come to terms with the idea that like, you're not gonna make it.
And it's not, it's not sudden,
it's not like someone shot you or you got hit by a bus or something like that.
It's like this hour long thing that you're getting dragged through all alone and
you, and you realize like no one will ever even know what this was,
you know how this happened.
And you think about all the people like Joshua Slocum, Jim gray,
people who were lost at sea and you realize they all had this thing that they
went through, you know, this hour long ordeal of just floating alone.
And no one will even ever know what that was or what that was like, you know?
And, uh, eventually I realized I was going to make sure I looked back,
the boat was like way far away from me. I started drifting back towards it.
I was still trying to swim. I,
I realized at some point that I wasn't going to hit it.
I wasn't going to hit the boat on the way back down wind.
And I had to just give it all that.
I had to try to connect with the boat, you know, to,
to stop myself from getting blown past it. And in that moment too,
you realize that like uncertainty is the most unendurable condition,
you know, that like you imagine yourself making it to shore and relaxing,
you know, just knowing that it's resolved. Right. And in that moment of like,
I might not make it back to this boat. You're,
you're like tempted to give up because it's the same resolution, you know,
it's the feeling of just knowing, you know, the, the,
the uncertainties have been resolved, you know,
and you have to really remind yourself that it's not the same, you know,
that like you have to give it everything you have in order to survive, you know?
And that,
that feeling that you're sort of longing for is not actually the feeling that
you want, you know? Uh, and I just barely got the,
the end of a rope that was trailing off of the back of the hole,
pull myself back on it almost threw up. Um, then I had to,
then I was just floating there with the, with the, the whole, you know,
three feet under water. I tied myself to it. Um,
I started to get tunnel vision and really at the last minute, um,
I S a tugboat, uh, started, uh,
coming through the area and it was coming straight at me actually. And I,
I realized that it probably just wouldn't even see me.
It would just run me over and not even know that I had been there, you know,
it's totally possible. Um, and I was just, you know, I was trying to like wave.
I could barely lift my arm. I was trying to scream.
I could barely make any noise. And somehow they saw me. And, uh.
They.
They, like, it took them like 15 minutes to like, get a rope around me.
And they started pulling me off the side of the boat.
And it was like lining every tugboat is, um, tires, like tires usually,
um, as like a fender, you know,
and I got like wedged in the tires as they were pulling me up and I knew what
was happening, you know? And I was like,
all I have to do is stick my leg out and push against the whole of the boat,
you know, to like go around the tires and I couldn't do it. Wow. Uh,
and I knew I could barely see, and they like swung me around.
It eventually pulled me up. They like put me in, uh,
next to the engines and the engine room. I couldn't, you know,
I couldn't even feel the heat. Uh,
and they called the coast guard and the coast guard came and got me.
It was like really embarrassing. And the coast guard, like, you know,
th th the coast guard guys, like, you know, he's like, God,
these blankets over me. And he's like trying to like talk to me to like,
keep me like alert, you know? And, uh, and you know, he's like, so is this,
is this your first time sailing?
And I'm like a commercial, like a 250 ton, like masters license, you know, like,
it's like, you need 600 days at sea to get this license, you know? Uh,
and I was like, no, I, I have a master's license. And he was like, what?
He's like, you're a idiot, man. You know, like everything changed.
The tone totally changed. Oh God dude, that's insane.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Jerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.